[Music]
welcome back to CBS Saturday morning we
move now to the nation's worsening
opioid epidemic and the new approaches
being taken to fight it over 100
000 people have died from drug overdoses
in the past 12 months the vast majority
from opiates including synthetic drugs
like fentanyl one place the problem is
especially acute is in Maine
for a subject that is overdose two doses
in that game with no faults on a Tuesday
afternoon police in Portland Maine
respond to an opiates overdose and
administer Narcan what has become the
go-to on-site treatment how bad is it in
Portland right now in Portland right now
we are currently 90 percent above where
we were this time last year double
where you were just a year ago correct
why
access Heath Gorham is Portland's
interim police chief when I started 22
years ago you know we very rarely saw
heroin we never saw fentanyl it was all
crack and over the years pills became
very prevalent and then we saw the
Resurgence of the opioids the street
drugs like heroin and then in the last
couple years we've seen fentanyl move in
fentanyl is not new
but on the streets it has reached new
levels for many departments already
overwhelmed so you have a warrant you
have four warrants for your arrest
there's four misdemeanor warrants but
they're not not a big deal there's Clear
Mountain Jesse Dana used to work in
corporate and retail sales for a
clothing company he's been a cop for 10
years do you have anything on you that's
going to get you jammed up accounting
because that is a felony if you've got
any drugs on you dude
a cop who like many others is now
expected to play multiple roles all
right buddy well if you need something
throughout the day let me know just uh
stay in the shade and kind of chill out
all right are you their friend are you
the police officer what are you you know
ultimately my job is to be a police
officer and to enforce the law but you
know if everybody down here you know is
a person just like you know the people
that I've worked with in my previous
career right so you have to treat
everybody with respect okay have you
checked in with your doctor most of the
folks that are dealing with being
unhoused are also dealing with the
substance use disorder and Behavioral
Health disorders so those co-occurring
disorders and a lack of treatment beds a
lack of inpatient treatment is leaving
them out there on the street and
Fentanyl is so incredibly easy to get
what helped do you need from the federal
government we need facilities for
inpatient treatment inpatient treatments
for drug addiction lacking on the
outside are now being pioneered on the
inside we went into the main State
Prison a maximum security facility for
those who've done the worst of the worst
often under the influence of drugs or
alcohol
like Earl buddy Beeler who's serving a
sentence for murdering one person and
nearly another in 2009.
at first even losing his freedom wasn't
enough to make him change his ways you
were using for a long time
when you came to prison yeah pretty much
the whole time the whole time until when
so I got some drugs that I ingested that
came out of someone's mouth
and it almost killed me put me incept
this had to go out on the ambulance you
and you injected someone's saliva well
the strips the Suboxone strip came out
of their mouth so it had some of this
saliva on it yes that's how desperate
you were for it yeah after recovering
from a near fatal infection dealer
eventually got into a new prison
treatment program under which he's given
Suboxone a drug that treats dependence
on narcotics
42 percent of people incarcerated here
are now being treated with suboxone a
strategy embraced by the commissioner of
Maine state prisons if we recognize that
addiction is is a disease we should
treat it that way Randy Liberty grew up
surrounded by a life of crime one of his
first Jobs when he entered law
enforcement was to guard his own father
unfortunately dysfunctionally it was
comfortable I come to the going to
Charlie block upstairs in the in the
jail morning Dad morning Randy and it's
some of the best time I've ever spent
with them Liberty has one main mission
here to normalize Corrections let me
take a look at it okay thank you nice to
meet you any of the states can adopt
what we're doing here and it really just
means reducing the stigma of being
incarcerated
stopping the shame part of that means
making a prison not look like one we're
uh aggressive with our agriculture not
only it smells nice yeah for example the
Abundant Gardens and even pickling
classes I think we did uh well maybe 3
000 tomato plants and pepper plants this
year and not only does it help them
therapeutically to raise that and feel
good about that but it also gives them
an opportunity to enhance nutrition our
job is to help the residents identify or
brought them here and then get to work
you know treating those those particular
situations a couple years ago you
stopped referring to the people here the
men here as as prisoners or inmates you
call them residents that's right you
know we believe language matters and we
believe that dignity and respect is is
deserved by all and so that's why we
call the individuals that are
incarcerated here residents even
murderers even murderers you know we
believe in Redemption Maine State Prison
says their treatment program has reduced
overdose deaths in residents after their
release
by 60 percent thank you when the
taxpayers of the state of Maine spend 46
thousand dollars a year to house a
resident here I think they demand that
we we get results it's a crazy Number
forty six thousand dollars forty six
thousand dollars a year and the ones
that are here need to be here you know
that's how we provide Public Safety they
need a reset they need to pause and
reflect and understand what brought them
to Corrections and then we need to get
to work to to assist them in
transitioning back into the community
anybody in the tent
Portland PD a community that doesn't
have to look far to see the evidence of
America's ongoing struggle with
addiction I could say that you could
probably have somebody spend their
entire day walking around just picking
up needles and they could probably fill
about four to five hours of their day
and the work that still needs to be done
to make help available without having to
go to prison to get it we're all part of
the community that's around here so
whether you're unhoused whether you live
in a home you know like these folks do
here whether you have a business or
whether you're a tourist you all have to
kind of do your part what do you think
the solution is for this or is this just
maintenance right now right now we're in
a maintenance phase I think a lot of
that has to do with the fact that
they're really there's not enough full
treatment centers for people that really
need help
and it's the cycle as Liberty as Randy
Liberty says the people who are here in
prison need to be in prison but if they
don't get fixed or get problems
addressed while in prison they go back
out they just come right back create
more problems for everyone else and end
up right back I thought it was
interesting because he said it is the
Redemption you have you have to solve
the problems there or it is to your
point a cycle that just repeats itself
and it is very costly to taxpayers forty
six thousand dollars right that's a
college education yep think about it
every year
good pizza